yeah three out of three for black you
won't see that very often at the top
level and uh that means that maybe ding
has to mix things up and no more english
opening that we saw from him two games
ago
it's back towards the queen's pawn when
we see the queen scan bit what do we
predict here key moment oh maybe the
nimzo okay no no nimzo for black
it's all about what pragmata chooses
here will black push a pawn in the
centre of the board will black star
squad bishop come out maybe give a check
you can go to the queen's gown bit from
this position you can go into the bononi
from this position queen's indian from
this position this is the moment where
you choose and look at pragmata he's
just looking away from the board he's
choosing what opening to play
he did not expect this but slightly
surprising this is ding's main opening
yeah it is his main opening it's also
quite logical because this is a lot
safer to pick up the
the knight on the right side
than uh develop the knight on the left
side and he chooses
something that is i don't know the name
of this what is it called i think it
transposes to a variation of the black
knight tango whoa
where the the knights kind of dance
around for black because they can get
kicked um this black knight that's just
jumped into
onto this c6 square the white pawn in
the center of the board can actually go
and attack it and the black knights
would actually have to do a bit of a
dance
i don't know if that's why it's called
the tango
but the black knights tango normally
starts without black touching any of his
pawns the black knights coming out on
their first two moves so i'm not sure if
it's a direct transposition but as far
as i know that's the closest
related opening so will this be one of
those other on our opening stats
i think so yeah wow doesn't count as a
queen's gambit because black's pawn is
not in the center of the board
i've never seen uh prague play this i've
never seen actually any player play this
on the champions chess tour
prague that's why he was thinking he was
just trying to surprise ding as quickly
as possible and ding
i don't think he's uh spent one minute
on any fourth move ever in the champions
chess door normally he knows his
openings inside out so big surprise
do the players actually can they see
each other or can they choose they can
choose yeah because i think fernando
looked up at the camera looked right
into the camera like as if he was saying
hmm what are you going to do
like that
it would be funny if he winked as well
oh yeah
i got some preparation in
that's a
that gives chess players a lot of joy
to get that in okay so meanwhile
yeah some really weird moves i've got to
say from pregnant especially um but
weird is good in this situation remember
he's in a must-win
scenario with black
that means you have to do something a
bit different
you have to surprise the opponent here
white is occupying the center and the
reason i say that this is weird for
black is because look at what he's doing
he's just treading water black is hiding
on his first three ranks not challenging
the white uh the white pawns in the
middle of the board and that's rare
conventional wisdom says you have to
challenge in the center of the board you
have to do something you can't allow
your opponent to control especially with
pawns and now depending on what pregnant
does it's black to play we could see a
direct transposition into the king's
indian
defense except white has won a move
white's pawn
on the a3 square normally that would be
back
on its starting square okay prague
meanwhile keeping his options open
moving the black rook i don't like this
last move i've got to say
from black i think that black's choices
here are quite limited you have to
develop you have to push one of your
pawns white's center is just too strong
right now yeah and the players are
actually still following theory
and uh this move is a little bit unusual
actually because it allows black to make
the following breakthrough and uh now we
have a very critical moment
you can either step forward with your
pawn or you can capture pawns and i
think bearing in mind what happened to
pragnanda yesterday against giri
do not step forward with the pawn
it's they're too complicated too wild
capture the pawn and it's going to be a
lot more harder for pragananda to
generate winning chances yeah and if if
the black pawn uh well if the pawn
structure had blocked up there would be
no trades it would be so much tension
and as yamanka mentioned you're quite
happy to see this exchange in a
situation where a draw is good for ding
yeah
i mean it's natural isn't it so now he
again there's a choice you know capture
with a pawn capture with a knight i
guess
you know you probably should capture
with the pawn keep as many pieces on the
board as possible the problem is the
queen trade might happen and uh a
drawish a drawer kind of
well it will suit ding but okay he does
play this and now i'm not
really
expecting um ding here to keep the
queens on the board because that would
allow again the situation full of
tension i expect the queens to come off
and they have and in this scenario
white's knight does have a nice outpost
in the center of the board blacks does
too this is a hole in white's position
for the black knight to jump into later
but
i don't know it's just so balanced white
has no real weaknesses and i'm i'm
slightly surprised i think maybe taking
with the knight keeping the center
closed this would have at least kept
more tension in the position the queens
would remain on the board and still
black is relatively active
but uh okay prague now in this current
position thinking of how to recapture
the queen maybe he wants to take back
with the knight so that at some point he
can push his pawn forward and control
the square that the white knight wants
to jump into
queen's off the board though it's going
to be hard for prague to win this game
ding is just being cynical he said this
in an interview before he said he was
being a bit dirty in his own words just
by trading everything off in a situation
where he only needed a draw well it's
loud you can always be smart it's within
the rules and i guess it's going to be a
tango game then you know the player's
time going back and forth
it's weird it started as a kind of black
knight's tango and then it turned into a
king's indian this looks exactly like a
king's indian position
um yeah it's just that pawn structure
now and again the player's just using
pattern recognition often openings
transform they change into each other
and you just have to recognize those
patterns that's why it's good to have a
vast kind of knowledge of different
chess openings you can't always play the
same thing every time at this top level
and
both sides freestyling but prague
thinking now how to recapture this white
queen and before today prague had played
zero kings indian on the tour with the
black pieces
ending with white
one yeah
no three three actually and one win one
draw one uh
black win okay oh lost for ding
over the board at least ding is known as
a bit of a king's indian killer he's
normally very good at punishing players
who play the king's indian
um ivanka you surprised
by the last few moves yeah slightly
surprised you know i was thinking that
maybe the play would be a bit more
dynamic from pragnanda and
this one looks like such a hard
hard task you know to try to win the
position from this against
ding who is so so strong and we're
talking about like fine margins this is
this is the thing these players are not
going to make huge blunders they're
going to if they're going to blunder
it's going to be small things
and in this type of position a small
blunder is actually not going to cost
the
game and even though we've seen three
black game
well
three games being won by the black
pieces um it's a lot harder to win when
you play with the black pieces if white
just wants to draw it's a lot easier if
white is pushing for a win to
to win aha so it's hard to be in that
must win yeah with the black pieces
definitely
i mean the reason you're right there
heidi completely the reason black won
the first three games is because white
was taking risks taking chances trying
to create
something out of nothing and
it rebounded on white in the first three
games today but
this one it's definitely a different uh
philosophy from ding
and okay he brings his bishop out
creating a pin on black's knight and
that white bishop now real nuisance
okay well pregnant he is spending some
time to think he has to win this game
now we do have our selfie challenge
today where you can win a signed
chessboard by anish giri and all the
selfies are coming in so let's take a
look at some of them
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so waiting for prank to win was the
message from that final selfie thank you
to everyone we enjoy so much seeing
yourself is and having you
with us while we watch the action and
chessable master is prague fighting so
hard to win this game to tie the first
match in the final he's been thinking
for such a long time now david this must
be very difficult he's been thinking for
a long long time and i think it's
because he's unfamiliar with this type
of opening which we mentioned kind of
reached we reached in a weird kind of
unusual way but it is quite a difficult
position in itself also remember prague
doesn't have to just look for moves he
has to look for moves that keep tension
that pose problems for ding and i think
that's the difficult part i think there
are maybe two or three moves which are
completely fine here for black but
none of them really create those winning
chances that he needs in this game
and yeah now down to eight minutes
already six minutes down on the clock
compared to ding it's getting critical
for prague already a big big moment yeah
and it kind of almost feels like
just a psychological opening nightmare
for the young indian and well
opening nightmare that is our quiz of
the day
an amazing prize up for grabs it's the
chessable course on the grand rue lopez
by niels grandelius and the elusive
panda says the worst opening
for me to face is black and is the
london i know it's going to be a long
game
sometimes opening does this to you and
meanwhile pragnanda has actually made a
move so he's moved his rook one square
up the board getting out of the eye line
of the dark squire bar reacts to this
yeah the bar reacts and the reason is
because it is quite a clumsy move the
rook as uh yomanka mentions gets out of
the diagonal of the white bishop but
look at this black bishop suddenly this
black bishop is trapped if you can't
move this black bishop you can't move
your rook in the corner either and uh
it's all because this pin was just too
frustrating ideally you want to move
your rook in a different direction but
if for example you move it back to the
center then we would see
for example a trade on this square maybe
even actually
thinking about it the white knight would
come in and start targeting this pawn if
the white knight gets to this square it
will hit not just one black rook but
another black rook in the corner so
black in a way had to play a move like
this or at least prague felt
compelled to play this move because he
defends his pawn and okay it was just a
temporary blockage of his own bishop
after the white rook slid across we see
a trade of rooks and
there is some hope for prague for
example in the current position um i
mean i'm assuming that white will take
back with his rook here maybe the white
bishop can actually slide back and
capture and go after this knight that
would be a very ding type of move a very
clever sophisticated idea there but if
for example he plays the most natural
move putting a rook on an open file then
the hope i see here for prague is that
he can bring his bishop out finally this
bishop was blocked and again if he gets
given a move or two then suddenly after
a trade he can establish at least one
good piece in the white half of the
board this is a beautiful outpost for
the black knight anchored by a pawn
at least one good square might lead to
better things later in the game still
takes a long long time to even create
any winning chances for black or even
dream of any winning chances for black
but
i think this is what he has to go for
wow
and uh it's looking good for dingley ran
in game four here let's head back to
simon at the good night who are they
cheering for the norwegian down at the
pub tonight simon
and to be totally honest i think they're
enjoying themselves too much
to be having a look so much at the
screen we've got the games up here on
the big screen but look how
everyone is just playing blitz and
having a good time here so everyone say
hello you're on tv
so um
hi hello hello okay that was that was
very calm hello but anyway we're uh yeah
we go through now and we check out some
other people in the in the bar so we'll
walk this way
and um well how i mean prague is doing
uh well but black's been winning every
game so far got some serious beard envy
going on over there that beard is
fantastic well done there
but we'll just walk along here and um
well let's ask this chap here um about
the candidates because obviously this is
the big event coming up yeah and um one
of the players will be in the candidates
fighting for the world championships do
you think it could be ding or you got
someone else on your mind yeah
maybe if you're sure or someone
you think
foreign yeah
okay well maybe frugia because if
ferugia does it that means magnus carson
will actually play which will be
fantastic but at the moment back to the
studio in a second because it is
obviously prague who needs to win this
game to give himself a chance in this
leg he definitely does simon thank you
so much that looks like a very good time
at the good night and uh dingley ran
world number two that must be a
motivation for magnus as well if ding is
the one that wins the candidates we did
have a couple of moves this is the
looking very hard for prague to win this
still going to be difficult purely
because there have been so many
exchanges so far a set of queens a set
of rooks already off the board but
still enough sufficient ammunition later
to create some imbalance still that hole
that we talked about on the d4 square
for black's knight to jump into
some hope for prac the bar says 0.3
advantage for for ding i have to say hi
did so the bar for me as a beginner in
chess is
my reference to understanding what is
going on on the board and it's something
we copied from nrk the show that you
have been working on for many many years
since magnus became world champion what
do you think is
the the
key to making chess understandable for
non-chess players i think it's just what
you're saying that to sort of tell the
viewers
who is better off because it's so
difficult to look at the board and and
realize
if you especially if you don't know a
lot of chess and even people at my level
it's probably easier for you but i think
for everyone it helps just to have the
bar to kind of understand a little bit
and the norwegian muse they love they
love the bar yeah it's um
a bar yeah look at the bar and we even
had a viewer um who who tattooed look at
the bar on her arm really yeah it's like
the best tattoo it's a part of it like a
bigger chest tattoo but it's uh it's
cool oh that's a challenge for our
viewers yeah anyone tattoo look at the
bar
[Laughter]
i say it a lot because again it is my
only reference to understanding you know
is is the score now one nil if you
reference to football is it five nil you
know is it nil nil what is the score
here simon loves the bar too maybe he
should just get involved
it works very well in english as well of
course with uh
you know simon being at the good night
bar
all the time and yeah you mentioned id
the bar but i mean it's useful for us
too i mean often we're looking at a
position and even though we're
decent players i mean even if there are
big blunders we won't necessarily see it
unless we see the evaluation bar swing
it's only having that kind of hint that
the computer gives us that's why we're
able to commentate and show some of
these variations often if it was a game
if we super stressed we wouldn't know
and uh i mean the players of course they
don't see it they don't know the
evaluation but
i think that's why it's it's quite nice
to kind of see it even as a strong
player my well decent player myself um
it's nice to kind of
see the swings and roundabouts in the
game uh it makes it more dramatic and
entertaining what is their reaction
among maybe more and we do have a mool
by the way yeah white's bishop going to
the edge of the board i mentioned the
black knight wants to jump into the
center so ding is trying uh just to
eliminate all chances of losing the game
by eliminating this black knight
talking of the bar though he's not a big
fan of that move slowly but surely maybe
drifting in black's favor
sorry kaia you are yeah i was just
wondering uh players your level watching
chess of course they have done for many
many years maybe not as used to having
the bar are they opposed to it or do
they like it do you think
i think everyone likes it to be honest
with you because it's a really good
indicator as david says you know whether
you know someone is doing well if
there's been a blunder and uh like david
also highlighted when there's a blunder
it's also this is the moment where we
can go ah okay this is what's happening
and you start looking and trying to
calculate and that is so handy i mean it
would be kind of cool if they introduced
chess with the bar
just the bar yeah how much would that
change the game at this top level
i think it would change a lot because uh
sometimes when you sit and play and also
like in all levels because when you sit
on plane you look at a move and then you
think
is it going to work if you have the bar
then you know there's at least something
that that works if it's like a big
advantage for your
for you
it means that blunders would almost
always be punished yeah yeah often a
blunder would happen and if you don't
see the bar you just trust your opponent
you just assume there's nothing there
but if you see your opponent makes a
strange move and suddenly the bar goes
in your favor you're like oh yeah that's
the moment yeah
the perfect example from from the match
in 2014 right in game six was it when
when magnus made a blunder but annan
didn't discover it and with the bar he
probably would have yeah definitely and
that was so uh um because i think that
showed like the the gay miners played
because you couldn't tell and tell at
all that he made it blunder except that
he stopped writing with his pen his hand
just stopped and that was all all the
signs that he gave but then i did not uh
that must have been a tense movement in
the nrk studio in 2014 a bunch of moves
any hope for prague definitely hope for
prague because the position is changing
i'm not sure whose favorite it is in but
as long as there are imbalances i think
that will make prague fans very very
happy and here we go prague does have
the bishop pair let's jump in to show
what has just happened um we left it
here just a few moments ago we mentioned
that black was actually trying to remove
the white knight just so the black
knight could jump into the center of the
board and ding said okay you can remove
my knight but i'm actually going to go
and double your pawn structure and
remove your strong knight potentially
prague decided okay you can do that but
uh okay rerouting his knight first of
all we saw a trade in the center of the
board and now white's knight stepping
back but it's all about the different
kind of um
selection here of minor pieces black has
the two bishops and position is
relatively open i can imagine this
bishop being very strong tying down
white's pieces to this pawn and the
other black bishop does have a future as
well at the moment staring at its own
pawn not great but if you look at the
route for this bishop you could step
back
round and into the center of the board
and it does take a few moves but
definite potential behind black's pieces
also this knight which is on the edge of
the board it's on the rim it's a very
dim piece right now it's about to leap
forward into the center adding extra
pressure onto this pawn there's a lot of
kind of built up uh pen top pressure um
that is going to come on the white
position from uh from the black minor
pieces but it is however a double edged
position because the weakness of these
pawns might become a factor later on and
uh ding was trying to remind prague of
his pawns dropping his bishop back
hitting this guy but price says okay i
don't care i'm stepping forward
actually it's quite hard to attack these
pawns in the short term so that is once
another factor on prague's side on
ding's side however of course it's not
just the pawns but the weaknesses of the
squares in front of them and this knight
is headed towards an outpost it's
imbalanced now though it's not a dead
position and that was my fear earlier
that ding would just swap off all the
pieces
get rid of all the winning chances and
just eliminate any hope but there is
hope
it might not be a big big kind of attack
here for prague but as long as he can
keep the game alive he will have chances
okay
good news for all the prague fans in
india and all around the world actually
we know he has a huge fan base already
the 16 year old coming from exams
earlier today and now fighting to tie
the match
it's uh dramatic if he uh isn't able of
course to win but he still has a match
tomorrow and he can still win that match
to take it to tie breaks it's not over
for prague he's definitely not over and
i don't know if he has exams tomorrow
that's the key question
i hope you can get a good night's sleep
we'll have to ask him whether he has
exams
but
oh
just imagine if he has another set of
exams we need to call his teachers yeah
i mean i don't understand why they made
him do it me neither
um okay well we have seen a set of
trades and the black knight has jumped
in to the middle of the board and
well there is a threat in the air knight
takes pawn
yeah there's pluses and minuses to this
decision from prague though i mentioned
that as long as you had the two bishops
you have long term hopes yes you had a
bad pawn structure but prac has decided
to trade at one bishop for one of the
knights and if you look at the two
bishops right now that remain on the
board they are of opposite colors white
bishop on the dark squares black's
bishop on the light squares in a way
they'll just kind of pass each other by
and balance each other out ivanka
mentioned it's like ships passing each
other in the night
yeah if the knights disappear i think
it's going to be a draw it's just about
the
knights and whether they can survive
yeah i agree but i do like the way that
prague has been playing this particular
position
these last few moves because you know he
has pushed his acorn alice she's gone to
the fourth row and it restricts white's
pawns on the left
yeah so these two white pawns are kind
of uh just completely immobilized by
this one black pawn for example if the
white pawn ever steps forward two
squares
say in this position then on passant
as if the white pawn had just moved one
square and suddenly everything's going
to drop for white this pawn is a
weakness this pawn is a big weakness and
actually this pawn i think is the key
factor
black's pieces are attacking it white's
pieces are tied down passively defending
and it will come down for example if
blackjuice waits it will come down to a
situation where ding has to decide does
he ever trade off a bishop for a night
if he trades off his bishop for the
black knight then suddenly the black
pawns are no longer doubled and black
will be able to correct his pawn
structure with a very mobile uh kind of
situation here he can push in the center
here he can push
over here just trying to open things up
for the bishop against the knight which
prefers blocked positions and uh okay i
was expecting prague to just slowly wait
improve his king maybe bring it closer
towards the center but he says no he
just steps back kicking away this white
bishop and wherever the bishop goes now
is his idea to bring his knight to this
side of the board is his idea maybe to
just swing his rook to the open file
we'll soon find out but the black pieces
are getting quite active maybe the rook
will come into the white half at some
point
it might come down to a situation where
it's just completely blocked and black
will have to open up the other side of
the board maybe with a pawn push he
needs to play on both flanks here i
think in order to win
later prague
yeah i think it's super important that
last point that you made about playing
on both sides of the board
and after ding has retreated the bishop
maybe this is something he needs to
consider seriously actually just uh
think ahead and visualize what pragnanda
might be doing and just put a stop to
that idea
um
the former world champion aletareli
karpov was famous for doing these type
of things
yeah and uh another thing that karpov
here i'm thinking another world champion
petrosian would be considering here is
for example black just pushing a pawn
just doing not too much and the reason i
want to push this pawn just to solidify
my pawn in the center and then okay he's
actually done this and i think he's got
a specific maneuver in mind i think he
wants to push his pawn one square
forward to kick away the white bishop
and when the bishop moves it looks weird
to put your pawns on dart squares where
they're targets but the whole reason is
that you've created a square in the
middle for your knight and there's
actually a clear path for it to get
there the black knight could step back
and back and into the center and for
example if we see this happening on the
board the black knight once it reaches
there it's on a protected outpost
no pawn can ever touch this knight and
if you ever trade off a bishop for it
again these pawns correct themselves
they uh well protected passport here for
black and easy targets for the rook
i think prague has got a really deep
strategic maneuver in mind and therefore
ding of course he spots it and uh if we
rewind before black gets a chance to
push this pawn ding says no i'm going to
block you off i'm going to control that
square myself
um it has come at the detriment of
white's bishop though white's bishop now
blocked in
prague he's making these big decisions
so quickly jumping to the side with his
knight hoping again for this trade
because i think the black rook now has
more targets than the white rook
but i don't think ding will exchange off
here maybe he'll just bring his king
towards the center
still roughly balanced i have to say you
know despite the position being roughly
balanced i really like what pregnant has
been doing i really like the
sophistication behind all his ideas i
think it's so instructive as well
and what the white king stepping forward
joining in the action but what next
that's the problem uh we mentioned
opposite color bishops while knights
remain on the board i don't think it's
such a big factor but now that the
knights have just left the board he's
traded off nights
if the rooks disappear it's a complete
fortress you'll never be able to break
through these bishops just cancel each
other out it's going to be a dead draw
it's all about the rooks now can i keep
them on the board right now white can't
use this open file because the bishop
controls this square so the white rook
is a bit stuck black's rook will get to
the open file but is it enough
i don't think it will be why did he
trade off knights if uh if it goes
towards the draw yeah i
good question heidi i don't really know
i think maybe he just didn't see
anything better but i would rather keep
them on and
even if the black knight wasn't great
i'd rather keep them on the board
uh i agree with you i just don't
don't see what's happening and
and look here we go the white rook is
actually about to enter the open line as
well uh for example if we see the black
rook swing across which is maybe even
the best move then we'll just see a
trade and here white will never conquer
the light squares black will never
conquer the dark squares it's just a
draw prague has to keep the rooks on the
board at all costs now
and okay he does that by pushing a pawn
but
it's not enough it's not enough simply
now it kind of almost feels like white
is better because white has the active
rook
i was just like singing pregnant as
praises and then he takes some very
mysterious decision of trading nights
and now i'm like i think it's just draw
and one of the other key things about
opposite color bishop endings alongside
um
that have rooks on them it's all about
control and white has control as well as
um an active rook
very very difficult for pragnanda to
to win this
yeah and white's bishop is just going to
protect all of its pawns what pregnant
needs to do now is somehow open up a
line on the king side on the right half
of the board for the black rook to come
through break through
i don't think ding has to allow that
though i think no matter which pawns you
push is black white will always be able
to block it up
and uh yeah i mean heidi you mentioned
changing off those black um changing off
the knights i think that's another key
question for viewers i mean of all
levels when to exchange pieces
and
sometimes maybe prague did a comparison
the black knight was on the edge of the
board the white knight was centralized
so it makes sense to exchange but if you
need to win
yeah you need knights on the board
imagine a knight in this position just
hopping around creating some trouble
maybe you're not winning maybe you're
not better even but at least you have
some chance to win the game
do you think ding is feeling confident
now he's gonna get at least the draw he
needs to win the match
he should be feeling confident he won't
relax too early i think that's one of
ding's strengths he's so focused all the
time he very rarely makes those one-move
blunders that we occasionally see from
other other grandmasters he's so focused
but
yeah i mean he's big big favorite now to
get the draw and look at his tour rating
just below his face today he has reached
2800
i guess with a jaw here though he will
drop down below 2800 but still an
amazing score yeah closing in on magnus
carlsen yeah he is world number two
fighting to win the match here we have
another move
yep the white rook steps back very
logical and black's pawns are coming
i'm not sure where they're going to but
uh they are advancing at least
do you guys see any chances here at all
for black i don't to be honest any
potential crazy plans
it's uh what film is it was like it's a
miracle
i think it's a i think it's life with
brian
which magnus is a big fan of i love it
yeah big fan of monty python yeah they
they follow brian around it's a miracle
that's america yeah sorry
so if that happens now yeah you have to
say that actually if the bar jumps up
for prague
it's going to be a miracle i guess the
last three world champions uh kramnik
and carlson they're all massive fans of
monty python really
fun fact i just remember being at a
dinner once in london and and andy
kramnik were just quoting back jokes at
each other and i was just sat there
being like what is this
are you a fan too um i am now at the
time i was maybe 18 at the time i i
hadn't been educated in the art yeah
so now
whenever we have a prodigy
like prague will have to ask by the way
what do you think about monty python
yeah and then if he says yes then look
out world champion
and what the players are
thinking i do want to show you one quick
tweet which is that's a selfie from lucy
liu who says great chess and commentary
got us through a few tough years now
we're on greener pastures and so are our
lambs peter ivanka judith aneesh levon
magnus jan kaya and david
oh
someone's named lucy's named her lambs
after us
oh oh that's like unbelievable sorry i'm
like super sweet i'm super excited thank
you lucy lou for sharing that with us
you've got to name the next lamb heidi
yes heidi of simon simon yep both of
them and uh when can we come visit our
uh
our name brothers and sisters
yeah whatever that is in the world yeah
wherever it is and uh i'm so excited
about that i've never had anything named
after myself either thank you yeah
very cool definitely
and uh yeah and once
the players are still very much deep in
thoughts
pragnanda really doesn't have too much
hope unfortunately we just have to show
maybe why there is almost zero hope at
this point and it's because as well the
black rook is actually stuck i was about
to say it stuck where it is if it goes
too far away if it goes to the other
side of the board the white bishop can
come and target some pawns instead the
black rook uh kind of keeps the white
bishop honest it slides across if the
white bishop moves there might be some
checks
some annoying ideas but in the current
position white is simply going to wait
nothing is going to change black can't
do anything simply if you push this pawn
forward um
[Music]
sorry if white for example makes a move
if you push this pawn forward white can
firstly just block things up
one open line will not be enough for the
black rook because the king can just
stop any entry squares but more than
that i think actually any winning
attempts pushing a pawn are actually
going to backfire on prague we would
just see a trader pawns and now white is
the one creating a past pawn
um let's i mean i want to say let's
catch up with the current position but
nothing at all is changing here ding is
offering that trade of road rooks which
we mentioned would end the game in a
draw instantly if the rooks come off
dead draw we're going to find out is
prague going to try and win or is he
just going to trade rooks and admit that
today has not gone well
oh his webcam is a little off we can see
he keeps rooks on the board yeah that's
good but we're going to see the players
repeat the moves and uh here we go ding
does take the first day
it's over
winning two games dingley ran is the
winner of the first match in the big
final we didn't see a big celebration he
immediately left the computer but i do
suspect a little bit of a celebration